[Music]
WK + Z the Dutch station breathe in
their tent on this house
[Music]
it's Tuesday May 30th you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey here June is
around the corner you [ __ ] get
ready to rock this summer is almost here
Memorial Day is done
leave the flags up on a [ __ ] respect
and get ready for another fun-filled
week you bad [ __ ] for starters
we got a podcast tonight 8 o'clock 11
o'clock [ __ ] East Coast time
be there or be square Thursday night I'm
at the flappers for a [ __ ] workout
with uncle Joey all the stupid [ __ ] in
my mind I put it down for an hour and we
just go it's a cheap show you got
nothing else going on what do you gonna
do with 10 bucks on a Thursday night
anyway we're here with queer you follow
me the sun's not out but all that
matters is that love and ray of light
from your nutsack to warm the people
around you I got myself tutorial
tremendous batches I got this right here
and this is the [ __ ] Tiger Woods smoked
on his prescription [ __ ] didn't at the
top you following that's what happens
these dumb [ __ ] want to do a
couple bikes and drink some cocktails
then they end up looking like [ __ ]
Eddie Munster in the picture get the
[ __ ] out a you a drunk [ __ ] [ __ ]
all that matters is were alive and
kicking we're rocking and rolling and
when I get no duis you understand me we
smoked and look at the [ __ ] sky we
don't need to drive around and beat go
on and be [ __ ] cool you follow me as I
speak the rain starting to come down but
who gives a [ __ ] uncle Joey's here all
four seasons like the [ __ ]
mailman rain sleet snow tornadoes
whatever the [ __ ] you got I'm there with
a cape and a [ __ ] cane standing there
with my nut sacs out waiting to say you
know what tornado licked my nuts
you got a podcast that's ready for you
from Sunday night me and Lee Capello
jump on it today and then tonight we
give you another one again the month
[ __ ] strong and we're starting to
strong the [ __ ] month of June strong
Sunday we had a tremendous podcast we'll
drop it on your during the [ __ ] week
but for now all that matters is today I
don't give a [ __ ] about Wednesday I
don't give a [ __ ] about Thursday what's
important to me is Tuesday and how you
gonna go out there and put a will on
these [ __ ] gentle [ __ ] you
know Johnny liberals and sure I love
Portlandia go [ __ ] yourself you got a
heads up jeez up hoes down [ __ ]
where's that reefer you were talking
about Joe I got a bunch of [ __ ] going on
your little meeting we got some jujitsu
yeah there's a new [ __ ] computer I
got a [ __ ] I got a thousand [ __ ]
things on my plate you understand me
but the most focused is I'm gonna
[ __ ] bust true today and [ __ ]
swing dick like I've never smelled it
before I know you dead listen if you're
leaving the house thinking who's gonna
suck my dick today you slept on it you
gotta have your focus set before you
even leave the [ __ ] house cuz they're
all gonna suck your dicks are they gonna
be that good you're gonna be a [ __ ]
savage you're gonna be a star that's all
that matters you understand I'm trying
to say do and I'm no [ __ ] genius it I
got left back in the seventh grade I got
a GED I got problems just like the other
guy but I don't give a [ __ ] you
understand me
because half these guys are walking
around with pH D's and they don't know
what the [ __ ] going on me I'm a dumb
[ __ ] and I see a trap before you [ __ ]
say so who gives a [ __ ]
well I have a PhD if you can act like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you can't figure it out
I can leave the house for the [ __ ]
Bay Inn that broke at 8:00 in the
morning and come back with a pound of
weed mm a [ __ ] cell phone
rollerskates you don't teach that a
[ __ ] school you know sound
trying to save the earth based on hard
[ __ ] see all this [ __ ] it's goes out
the window because my heart oversees
[ __ ] that we think heart is the
[ __ ] main thing here that drives me
every [ __ ] day I think about my life
brother you know if it wasn't for my
[ __ ] heart I wouldn't be here I'd be
some [ __ ] half a [ __ ] with sideburns
and [ __ ] telling stories yeah who gives
a [ __ ] you gotta wake up
you got a sling that you gotta go for
the [ __ ] stars while the rest of
these [ __ ] are worried about
sign that rise you got your finger of
death [ __ ] skirt finger Magnum to
death don't even know what the [ __ ]
going on and that's just the beginning
understand me
I'm laying on your deep on a Tuesday cos
is what you need you have the day off
yesterday you were eating potato salad
with your [ __ ] friends I handed up
all [ __ ] day I'm bringing back that
writ back to [ __ ] focus on what you
need to do tell a [ __ ] to make it
happen you gotta stab my mother for
whatever listen whatever it takes right
why you keep lying to yourself pulling a
[ __ ] Bernie Madoff will find yourself
why how'd it go Bernie Madoff find
yourself [ __ ] sling dick give our
bubble gum be honest and go for it you
understand me and if you [ __ ] up today
you got tomorrow to get your [ __ ]
crayons back it's that easy the question
the days who's better than you that's it
when you get the answer to that [ __ ]
question it all works out you follow me
I should do and people to see will do
one more ball and we'll call that they
will wrap this [ __ ] up but now
you got the instructions for the day if
I'm being [ __ ] am almost trying to
bother me ever see mission impossible
the old school learnt that I would sit
on a park bench and also some guy would
drop off a [ __ ] newspaper I have the
tape recorder also the press interface
would pop up and Colombo's instructions
well for the day
that's me [ __ ] okay you sit there
poop and top up go get them stab him in
the nose go get the right whatever the
[ __ ] you need to do I'll give you the
instructions and that's the end of the
day what more bowling I [ __ ] they're
doing people see I never do you were
waiting for me [ __ ] who you kid
what more balls and then you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you need to do get
your notebook out write your goals down
make your plan your plan is to hold
listen to a football team before they do
a play they got a plan what makes you
any [ __ ] different you want to be
high-tech you gotta have a plan
if not well you need a fancy suit for
Charlie you got no job to worry that you
understand me I had told the yesterday
the church even if we do the podcast
twice a week I wear my uniform seven
[ __ ] days a week for the church which
means I give you a hell right now but I
don't give a [ __ ] we got nothing to
[ __ ] lose but I'd dignity you follow
me
so smoke drink a glass of milk bill
you're trying to push ups for the
[ __ ] soldiers and get out there and
tell these [ __ ] who's running
things you follow me that's it and
that's that
see you tonight eight o'clock tonight
I'll see you Thursday a [ __ ] flap is
7:30 ready to go you'll be home by 10
o'clock with two [ __ ] numbers in here
and your head will be spinning I have a
great day stay black uncle Joey loves
you tell them all to suck your dick bye